تحت شعار ميسر الوصول للعداله بتقنيات
رقميه انطلق اليوم المؤتمر العدلي الدولي
في نسخته الاولى بالعاصمه السعوديه الرياض
بمشاركه 50 دوله واكثر من 4000 مشارك من
مسؤولين وخبراء في القطاع العدلي يهدف
المؤتمر لبحث سبل تطوير القطاع العدلي
وتنميه الخبرات وتبادل المعرفه لتيسير
الوصول الى العداله اهلا وسهلا وزير العدل
السعودي وليد الصمعاني اول ترخيص لمكاتب
محاماه اجنبيه في السعوديه
الوزير قال خلال كلمته في المؤتمر العدلي
الدولي ان المؤتمر يستهدف بناء الشركات
العدليه ونقل التجارب والخبرات لتطوير
ممكنات العداله حول العالم وشدد وزير
العدل على ضروره مواكبه التغيرات لتحسين
وتطوير ما يتعلق بالتقنيات المعززه
المعززه والتحول الرقمي للضمانات القضائيه
والعدليه
ياتي هذا المؤتمر تاكيدا لرياده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في مختلف المجالات ومنها
القطاع العدلي الذي يحظى بدعم واهتمام من
لدن خادم الحرمين الشريفين والسمو للعهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان رئيس مجلس الوزراء
وايضا تاكيد للمكانه التي وصلت لها
المملكه على المستوى الدولي كان التفاعل
كبير جدا من العديد من الدول وصل عدد
المشاركين الى اكثر من 50 متحدث ومشارك
وكذلك التفاعل كبير جدا من مختصين
القانونيين لا شك اننا نامل ان يكون بعد
هذا المؤتمر تواصل كبير بين العديد من
وزارات العدل على مستوى العالم في معرفه
اثار التحولات الرقميه والضمانات القضائيه
وترسيخ قواعد العداله من خلال التفاهم
وتبادل الخبرات والاثراء المعرفي بين
مختلف الدول
من المؤتمر العدلي الدولي بالرياضي انضم
الينا مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز نواف مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض كيف جرت فعاليات اليوم الاول
للمؤتمر العدلي الدولي في الرياض
نعم نايف مرحله جديده سيشهدها القطاع
العدلي في السعوديه مع تنظيم النسخه
الاولى من المؤتمر العدلي الدولي
والمشاركه الواسعه من وزراء العدل من دول
عربيه هو اجنبيه وايضا الاعلان اليوم عن
الترخيص لاول ثلاث مكاتب محاماه اجنبيه
للعمل في السعوديه في المشاريع وغيرها
بالتعاون مع مكاتب المحاماه السعوديه
والمحامين السعوديين في هذا اليوم بدا
المؤتمر بافتتاح من وزير العدل الدكتور
وليد الصمعاني وايضا جلسات حواريه شارك
فيها وزير العدل مع وزيره العدل التونسيه
اضافه الى النائب الوكاله الاوروبيه
للتعاون القضائي ناقشوا فيها العديد من
المحاور التي تتعلق
بالقضاء والتحول الرقمي المؤتمر لازال
مستمر وسيكون الان المهندس ياسر السديس
وكيل وزاره العدل للتحول للتطوير والتخطيط
اهلا وسهلا مهندس ياسر في البدايه لماذا
هذا المؤتمر ينظم والى ماذا يهدف حياكم
الله وشكرا لكم على هذه الفرصه مؤتمر
العدل الدولي انطلق بشعار انه ييسر الوصول
للعداله بتقنيات رقميه وذلك لاستغلال
التحول
والتسارع في التحول الرقمي عالميا وفي
يعني توفير العداله للمستفيدين هذا
التسارع واستغلاله يعني فرص كبيره جدا اتى
هذا المؤتمر لبحث هذه الفرص لبحث تحديات
التحول الرقمي في تطبيقه في العداله هل
سيحدث هناك تحديات الاشكالات فلذلك
استقطبنا ولله الحمد خبراء من جميع انحاء
العالم من شرق العالم وغربي شاركوا معنا
من المتخصصين في مواضيع مختلفه كلها تناقش
فرص استغلال التحول الرقمي المتسارع في
تطوير الوصول للعداله للمستفيدين وكذلك
التحديات وكيفيه معالجتها ومناقشتها
الوزاره تهدف من هذا المؤتمر الى كذلك
مشاركه تجربتها في التحول الرقمي والسبق
العالمي لله الحمد الذي حققته في مختلف
المجالات في التحول الرقمي
والتحديات التي واجهتها في الوصول لهذا
التحول ثم المستقبل الذي تطمح اليه وتطمح
لتحقيقه باستغلال الوسائل الرقميه التي
ستساعد لتحسين تجربه المستفيدين تيسير
الوصول للعداله انجاز الوصول للعداله
باسرع صوره ممكنه باذن الله نعم كيف سيكون
شكل القضاء والمنظومه العدليه في السعوديه
بعد هذا المؤتمر وخلال السنوات القادمه
باذن الله سيحدث هناك تحول كبير استمرارا
للتحول الذي يحصل حاليا من خلال رؤيه
المملكه 2030 ومن خلال برنامج التحول
الوطني
كذلك احد اهداف هذا المؤتمر هو بحث
الفرص التي ممكن ان يتشكل فيها المستقبل
كيف سيكون شكل المستقبل للعداله في ظل
التحول الرقمي متسارع وخصوصا فيما يتعلق
بالذكاء الاصطناعي لذلك تلاحظ ربما في
برنامج هذا المؤتمر اكثر من جلسه تناقش
الذكاء الاصطناعي واثاره واليات تفعيله
واستغلاله في
تطوير
البرنامج العدلي عموما مهندس ياسر مكاتب
المحاماه التي رخص لها اليوم كيف ستدعم
قطاع المحاماه في السعوديه
ولا الحمد ترخص اليوم لمكتبين بريطانيين
ومكتب امريكي كاول ثلاثه مكاتب محاماه
اجنبيه
ورخصه السعوديه
هذه المكاتب حرصنا ان تكون من ذات المكاتب
الادوات الخبره العاليه او العميقه سواء
اعداد العقود او التقاضي فلذلك نتوقع دخول
مثل هذه المكاتب للسوق السعودي سيسهم في
اثراء السوق في اثراء المنافسه في تطوير
السوق السعودي في تدريب المحامي السعودي
في كذلك يعني نقل تجربه
بعض الدول المتقدمه في طريقه تعاملها مع
هذه القضايا المعقده لخصوصا وان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ولله الحمد تمر بتجربه
تحوليه سيدخل الكثير من الاستثمارات سيكون
هناك موجه كبيره من المستثمرين الاجانب
سيدخلون السعوديه لذلك هناك حاجه كبيره
جدا لوجود تطور كبير جدا موازي في قطاع
المحاماه الشكر لك مهندس ياسر
العدل حقيقه هي الاجدر بتنظيم المؤتمر
العدلي الدولي والتركيز على التحول الرقمي
نظرا لان وزاره العدل هي الاكثر تقدما في
تحقيق التحول الرقمي ضمن رؤيه 2030 وقد
حققت مؤخرا المركز الاول في مؤشر في قياس
التحول الرقمي الحكومي بنهايه هذا العام
وتعمل على العديد من الخطط والمبادرات ضمن
برنامج التحول الوطني للتحول الرقمي
واستخدام التقنيات في المنظومه العدليه
بالمملكه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من المؤتمر
العدلي الدولي بالرياض الى مراسل العربيه
نواف عزيز